i would say mendes influence on me from
that time looking back was the fact that
my father worked for the city government
and my mother was interested in city
life so it was natural for me to think
that it's important to be part of a city
of a group of a community and an
important part of your life is involved
in work that will keep you in touch with
other people in the community that's
certainly what their live showed and it
also showed me there are a million ways
that you could possibly have that
connection with the community but i can
remember thinking when i was a teenager
and we had some friends who lived you
started out saying it was a suburb it
wasn't a suburb and i wondered how could
people live in the suburb because if
they lived in a suburb they wouldn't
really be in touch with what's going on
in the city and i understood after a
while but but that that part civic life
community life whether it was temple
emanuel or whether it was the city
school board or that was a school
department or whether it was the United
Nations Association my more she worked
in political campaigns sometimes my
mother so that that I think had a
tremendous influence in in my life I
haven't really developed a theory of the
law didn't try to develop a theory until
I thought it was necessary and it isn't
really a theory to explain to people how
our court works and how I and others try
to think about the application of the
Constitution to problems that come up in
front of the court I mean that led me to
write about it and that's what you're
thinking about and and of course I
suppose that the heart of the
Constitution but it isn't only me it's
sandro Connor who had a very different
backgrounds you have done a ranch
interestingly enough we've talked about
this Tony Kennedy to Tony Kennedy's
really from San Francisco Sacramento
Northern California but I think in my
own case it puts I see the Constitution
is having the democratic process at the
heart of it
of having it the the the central element
of the Constitution is creating
institutions so people can decide things
for themselves and often I like to refer
back and say well that's probably what
the founders had in mind or the framers
had in mind when they thought of the
Greek city-states or were they were
writing the Constitution but perhaps
since you raised the point it's also
what i saw in Sam